[Music]
Angry Birds movie number one people love
this film yeah
you must been happy with how well it's
doing yeah no is incredibly happening
it's really funny yeah it's very funny
movie you have you're going like wow
just like did I just go wow wow
now are you Angry Bird red bird yeah
from what I understand they're birds in
it yeah bears yes very angry birds I
have seen the movie have you
start with a video game yeah and
obviously massively successful video
game were you into the video game we're
into video games at all I know I the
Star Wars version of it on a plane once
but I don't like video get I get very
competitive brings out a weird
competitive side of me that I was like I
just show this thing earlier I don't
like video games because I think because
I'm not very good at them but also I get
confused like I get
I literally have trouble walking they're
getting so sophisticated that my
character is always leaning against a
wall yeah and then the guy that note I
was obsessed you guys remember Goldeneye
it was on I would play Goldeneye and
this his kid named Steve knew the game
really well and if you were a [ __ ] he
knew were you so if you got shot and
when you got shot in that game I went
like that because it was James Bond yes
and he knew where you were gonna be were
you would he knew the games well he knew
where you would appear and you so you
would appear and he would just be there
and he would shoot you and you would
always go headshot so you're a
competitive guy I was gonna get mad
wouldn't have picked that up but yeah I
bring it out in you yeah I got mad at
him and I threw the controller at him
and I called him a sloppy [ __ ] never
called anybody before heard my lucky you
called him a what a sloppy [ __ ] and
then I ago you were sloppy [ __ ] and I
threw it at him and then everybody was
like sloppy [ __ ] and even he was like
sloppy [ __ ] and then a couple years
later I was playing ping-pong with
somebody and he was cheating he had very
long arms and he was going over the net
and he kept beating me and I go you
sloppy [ __ ] and I threw a thing
there was like there you are with the
sloppy [ __ ] again so I'm afraid I'm
gonna be playing Angry Birds and I'm
just gonna yell sloppy [ __ ] to myself
for right
you